THE WAY MOST PEOPLE LIVE
THEIR LIVES.
GREAT CONVERSATION, MOLLY
AND CHRIS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
AS I JUST MENTIONED, THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOMETHING MORE
NEFARIOUS GOING ON HERE LIKE
THEY WANT YOU TO LOCK
YOURSELF DOWN ALMOST.
AFTER ALMOST TWO YEARS OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE LARGELY
STAYING HOME DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC, MOST AMERICANS
WERE READY TO HIT THE ROAD,
BUT ACCORDING TO A NEW
REPORT BY "MORNING CONSULT"
THE INFLATION OF
RECORD-BREAKING GAS PRICES
ARE MORE RESPONSIBLE FOR
KEEPING FOLKS ARE THEIR
VACATION THIS HAS SUMMER
THAN COVID.
HERE NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
AUTHOR OF "DEFEATING BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM."
NEWT, IT'S AMERICAN AS APPLE
PIE THE IDEA OF HOPPING IN
YOUR CAR AND TAKING A SUMMER
ROAD TRIP WHETHER YOU'RE
SINGLE OR MARRIED AND HAVE
KIDS.
THAT'S PART OF THE AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE.
THAT IS BEING DETERIORATED
RIGHT NOW.
>> SURE, LOOK, EVERY ASPECT
OF AMERICAN LIFE IS BEING
DETERIORATED RIGHT NOW.
ONE LADY WAS REPORTED FROM
WASHINGTON OR PENNSYLVANIA
SAYING SHE HAS TO GO TO FOUR
OR FIVE STORES TO FIND BABY
FORMULA AND SHE CAN'T AFFORD
THE GASOLINE TO GO TO FOUR
OR FIVE STORES.
SO THESE BECOME COMPOUNDING
DISASTERS.
YOU HAVE A RISING CRIME
RATE.
YOU HAVE NUT CAKE LEFT-WING
D.A.'S WHO WON'T KEEP PEOPLE
LOCKED UP.
SO THE CITIES HAVE BECOME
WORSE.
YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
-- AND I THINK THE EARLIER
CONVERSATION WAS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THE BIG DIFFERENCE WAS NOT
PERSONALITY.
BILL CLINTON MADE A DECISION
IN THE FALL OF 1995 THAT IN
ORDER TO GET RE-ELECTED, HE
WOULD SELL OUT THE LEFT AND
MOVE TO THE CENTER AND SIGN
WELFARE REFORM, SIGN A
BALANCED BUDGET, DO WHATEVER
IT TOOK, BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTOOD HE DIDN'T CHANGE
HIS POLICIES WORDS WEREN'T
GOING TO WORK.
THESE PEOPLE CAN'T CHANGE
WHO THEY ARE AND THEY'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A DISASTER.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE AT
EVERY LEVEL.
THE GOVERNOR OF PENNSYLVANIA
JUST SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT WILL PUNISH
WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA FOR
PRODUCING NATURAL GAS.
THIS IS AT A TIME, BY THE
WAY, WHEN THE MARCELO SHALE
HAS 400 YEARS' SUPPLY
SITTING RIGHT THERE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
BUT THE GOVERNOR CAN'T GET
OUT OF IT BECAUSE HIS LEFT
WOULD RATHER PUNISH
PENNSYLVANIAN IN THE NAME OF
THEIR -- PENNSYLVANIANS IN
THE NAME OF THEIR IDEOLOGY.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE THIS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN
CHANGE.
I THINK IF THEY TRY TO
CHANGE, THEIR PARTY WILL
HAVE A CIVIL WAR.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY,
NEWT, THIS IS ALL EXTREMELY
HILARIOUS TO JOE BIDEN.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHY ARE GAS PRICES SO
BAD?
>> ESTIMATELAR SITUATION --
SIMILAR SITUATION BECAUSE
OF, YOU KNOW, A WAR IN
UKRAINE, GAS PRICES AND FOOD
PRICES ARE EXTREMELY HIGH.
THE IDEA WE'LL BE ABLE TO
CLICK A SWITCH AND BRING
DOWN THE COST OF GASOLINE IS
NOT LIKELY IN THE NEAR TERM
NOR IS IT WITH REGARD TO
FOOD.
>> THAT'S A WINNING MESSAGE
FOR THE VICTOR, ISN'T IT,
NEWT, THIS MORNING IN
AMERICA.
>> THIS IS A LEFT WING JIMMY
CARTER.
CARTER WAS INCOMPETENT, BUT
HE WAS SORT OF RATIONALE.
BIDEN IS INCOMPETENT AND
HE'S COMMITSED TO A SET OF
VALUES THAT ARE WRONG --
HE'S COMMITTED TO A SET OF
VALUES THAT ARE WRONG.
MY GUESS IS DEEP DOWN HE
LIKES HIGHER GASOLINE
PRICES.
IT DRIVES PEOPLE TOWARDS
SOME KIND OF NEW APPROACH.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
PRICE OF FOOD.
WHY ARE YOU EATING BEEF ANY
WAY?
YOU KNOW, YOU COULD BE A
VEGAN AND EVERYTHING WOULD
BE LESS EXPENSIVE OR YOU
COULD HAVE A VICTORY GARDEN
AT HOME.
HE CARES MORE ABOUT TAKING
CARE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THAN HE DOES ABOUT TAKING
CARE OF AMERICANS, AND THE
RESULT IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS COMPETING FOR
BABY FORMULA TO TAKE CARE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AGAINST
AMERICANS WHO COULDN'T FIND
THE BABY FORMULA.
YOU GO DOWN THIS LIST AND
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM OF
PERFORMANCE.
THE PROBLEM OF POOR BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST VALUES
THAT ARE ANTITHETICAL TO THE
AMERICAN FUTURE AND TO THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
IT'S A GENUINE CRISIS OF THE
SYSTEM.
>> Laura: NEWT, I'VE SAID
THIS BEFORE AND I WOULD LOVE
YOUR TAKE ON THIS, TO ME IT
SEEMS THE ONLY WAY THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY MIGHT
REEXAMINE ITS PRIORITIES
NOW, ITS VALUES RIGHT NOW IS
A 1984 WIPEOUT IN 2024, AND, AND
A SIGNIFICANT WIPEOUT IN
MIDTERMS.
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
CATACLYSMIC DEFEAT IN 2024
WHERE NEW ENGLAND STATES GO
AND MAYBE WE GET ROCKY
MOUNTAIN STATEMENTS FOR THE
NEXT PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
WE'RE REALLY IN THE FOURTH
GREAT WAVE.
REAGAN IN '80 WAS THE FIRST.
WE WERE THE SECOND IN 1994.
IN 2010 IN THE HOUSE, THE
RESULTS WERE ACTUALLY BIGGER
THAN IN '94.
JOHN BOEHNER'S TEAM GOT 64
SEATS AND WE GOT 53 SEATS.
THIS IS THE FOURTH BIG WAVE
IN THIS DIRECTION AND,
AGAIN, WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
DEMOCRATS GO OFF THE RAILS.
THE TRUTH IS THAT OBAMA WAS
ANTI-PETROLEUM,
ANTI-GASOLINE AND DIESEL
FUEL AND HEATING OIL AS
BIDEN IS AND IT LED TO A
REBELLION, BECAUSE PEOPLE
UNDERSTOOD IT.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
FACED WITH NOW, THE ONLY
HOPE FOR THE AMERICAN FUTURE
TO RETURN TO SANITY IS A
HUGE REPUBLICAN VICTORY THIS
FALL FOLLOWED BY A
REPUBLICAN PARTY BEHAVING
LIKE A GENUINE REFORMED
PARTY AS WE DID, AND
FOLLOWED BY A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WHICH IS
CATACLYSMIC FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: YOU'RE DARN
RIGHT.
>> REMEMBER, IT TOOK THE
REPUBLICANS FROM 1932 INTO
THE 1950'S TO FINALLY COME
TO GRIPS WITH THE REALITY OF
FDR.
IT COULD EASILY TAKE AN
ENTIRE GENERATION FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO FIGURE OUT THEY
CAN'T BE THIS CRAZY AND